[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
revealing the role of mononuclear
phagocytes in human pregnancy via
automated high purity isolation i'm
susie valdez of lab roots and i will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots and brought to you by multne
biotech to learn more visit them at
miltnybiotech.com now we encourage you
to participate today by submitting any
questions you might have during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation you may also submit any
technical issues here as well if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speakers dr
salvador vinto
asturias a global manager product
manager for cell separation reagents at
miltoni biotech and joining him today is
professor kathy thornton professor of
human immunology at swansea university
and medical school
welcome to both of you
dr uh dr
vince astorias you may now begin your
presentation
thank you very much for this kind of
introduction and welcome everybody to
the webinar today
we will be talking about uh the
molecular phagocytes in human pregnancy
and i will shortly talk about uh
separation strategies
that might be interesting to all of you
as well
so
i will start
let's see if this works yes
um i will start the first 15 minutes of
the webinar by talking about how does
magnetic cell separation work
and the different strategies of cell
adulation that we can find with or
without density gradients since we're
talking about blood products today i
thought that would be the most relevant
and then we'll see as well which are our
automated solutions and why they benefit
a lot with uh from
our
our reagents benefit a lot from these
automated solutions to get this high
purity uh cells that we all seek for
then um cassie will take over with a
case study for today uh about the
mononuclear phagocytes in human
pregnancy and she will really show how
these high purity isolations really
helped her to
enable these studies about monotheir
phagocytes
so
let's start with a quick overview
of uh milton in biotech we started
the company started in 1989
by stefan miltoni he was a pioneer in
cell separation which is the
what i'm going to be talking about today
he created this
solutions which have been growing quite
a lot since then the company has grown
now up to 4 000 employees
with more than 50 nationalities within
our staff and what i think is more
important about miltonian tells about
ourselves is that we have a quarter of
our employees working in r d so we are
really pushing for innovation we didn't
stop since
1989 and we continue to push forward
with the innovations not only in cell
separation but also in different areas
of research
let's start with uh how does magnetic
cell separation work it has three key
steps and three key components the first
step is magnetic labeling and we find
here the first component which are the
microbeads
they will
they are antigen specific and they will
label the antigens that you see that you
are interested in
on the second step we find the next two
key components which is the magnet and
the column
the column can amplify
the magnetic field and this allows us to
achieve minimal labeling of our cells
leaving more than 70 percent of our
epitopes free for you to to use
afterwards should you need to for
example inflow cytometry so since we
have now the cells labeled from step one
we apply them on the column in step two
and by gravity this the sample will flow
through the column and unlabeled cells
will flow through our tube our
collection too if we are interested in
our positive positively labeled cells we
then take the column out of the magnet
and then we plunge down ourselves and
then here we find our positive fraction
so if you're interested in the cells
that you were labeling you will have
your cells in the step three if you're
interested in cells that you are not
labeling you will have the cells in step
two
and i said that the column was important
because it allows us to achieve minimal
labeling but there's another point of
the column that is even more important
and that is taking control of ourselves
and this is important because we can
then control if i want higher purity
higher recovery or a balance of both and
we can control this by changing the flow
rate of our uh
by which the sample is going through the
column if we see the first animation
the sample goes pretty fast down and
then we out we select for high purity if
we go for intermediate speed we will
select for an
average between uh purity and recovery
so you would have like a balance between
the both and if we're interested in
enriching our sample and we want very
high recovery we go into a very slow
flow rate and
we can then uh select for higher
recovery
this is an example here and you we can
achieve this both in in manual selection
in manual installations i mean um or
automatic in manual isolations we will
change the type of column that we use
and in automatic isolation we'll change
the fluidic systems and the flow the
flow rate of that physics system
so now that we know how this works let's
see how this what is the
our solutions and how it works with
blood samples
the typical uh workflow is we get our
sample we will proceed to isolate our
pvmcs via density gradient
centrifugation we will then pick our uh
pvmc from that from the density gradient
and once we have the pvmcs then we can
isolate our target cells here we have
there are two solutions the positive
isolation in which we our microbeads
will bind the target cells or untouched
isolations where our microbeads will be
targeting
all the cells except our target cells
this process here depends obviously of
having the pvmcs first so the testing
gradient is key to get this but density
ingredients have been used for a long
time and as i said milton is very
focused on innovation so we have created
an another protocol in which you don't
really need to do density gradients
anymore you can isolate and touch the
vmcs with one of our newer kits and then
from those fivenc's then you can use
uh them normally to with other or
microbeads to isolate your target cells
and as you see also here in the top
there is also an arrow going directly
from the sample to our target cells and
that is because we also have some kits
that allow us to isolate directly the
cell of interest from our sample
and we have these kits available for
positive and touchy solutions for the
different blood products whole blood
puffy code lrc and local pack
and today we're talking about uh
monocytes mainly we're to have a look at
a quick look at the different uh
solutions that we have for these
cell types
if we already have pvncs isolated we
have several different available kits
here
i've taken the liberty to add the
product numbers so you guys can take a
screenshot
and uh have a look after what's on the
website uh we have directed the positive
oscillations for on the cd14 for example
the c40 microwaves and c14 microwaves
ultra pure and then we have uh
isolations which are untouched for
palminosites classic mono classical
monocytes and cd14 and c16 positive
on the right side of the presentation we
see the ones that are direct from our
sample and we have here our straight
from portfolio from different uh
blood products
to isolate our city 14 micro bits
and i've also mentioned that we have a
kit for bbmc isolation and this is a
huge step forward compared to the
density gradients because it's faster
and it's als it allows us to standardize
our results and let's see why
so
our new kit to isolate pvmcs allows us
to isolate in 25 minutes our over pvmcs
from the starting plot sample and it has
very few steps and very very simple
we first have a sedimentation of the
erythrocytes we then collect the
supernata we collect the supernate and
we spin we collect on the supernatant
and and and then
we can incubate our uh with our reagents
for 10 minutes
put it on our auto max for example or
multimax which i will talk about later
and 25 minutes later i have we have the
pbmcs this process here can be automated
as soon as this incubation starts so you
only really have around 10 minutes of
hands-on time
this allows us to have very clear pellet
with no red blood cell contamination and
also no granola set contamination
this is untouched isolation and for
positive isolation we have our
strain from protocols which allow us
also to go very quick from our starting
sample to our
cells of interest
we firstly dilute the
the blood sample
we add our microbeads
we incubate for around 15 minutes in the
fridge and then we run the sample
through our multi-max or the auto max
depending on the instrument you have in
hand
so using this you can achieve very high
purity of your cells very quick after
from your blood samples and you can
really
reduce the variability between the
different users that are
are doing cycles in your lab
so
here we can see the multimax and i would
really put
a lot of attention to our instruments
here because they really help especially
straight from an untouched pmc
isolations get to the next level and
really standardize the different
protocols
and this is important because
if you go to automation you achieve
several different things you can get you
can standardize your processes so you
really reduce human errors you can
really make it reproducible because it's
always the same protocol this not it's
going to be it's not going to change if
different people in your lab or
or technicians are doing the
same these protocols it's more efficient
because you reduce the hands on time and
so you can work on other tasks you can
prepare for your downstream applications
and it also increases your users user
safety reducing contaminations and
employee exposure to samples
and below you can see from low
throughput to high throughput the
different solutions that we have
the first ones are obviously manual
for lower throughput laps and but it
really makes sense to go for instruments
as soon as you get to mid throughput
because you can really take advantage of
the automatic features
and the other some of the auto max
features um are going to be listed here
it's very interesting for multi-user
labs that that have several separations
per week per day
as well um it can do one to six
separations per run
um one important feature is that you can
reuse the columns they last up to two
weeks so if you really run a lot of
samples
and also larger samples it's really
faster and it really helps you
reduce the costs on columns
it has hyperproducibility
representability across experiments
and is a perfect fit for automated
isolations from from a wide range of
starting materials and most of our kids
are compatible with the automats as well
and then if we move towards more high
throughput or higher volumes we then
find the multi-max cell 24 separator
plus
this
instrument allows us to put up to 24
columns on it so we can run from between
1 and 24 samples per run and this is
really good when you have either a lot
of samples or samples with high volume
because it's going to be much faster
than the than doing it manually of
course
and then
finally it's fast and straightforward
and it really really shines with a high
volume samples and a
high number number of samples as well
and so this brings me to my summary
where um you can take a screenshot maybe
if you're interested on our untouched
bbmc isolation kit on the left side you
can find the page with more information
and then you can ask us for more and on
the right side there's the our cell
separation website where you can really
find any solutions that you seek for
a quick
disclaimer for all of you
and then i will move to cassie where she
will be really showing you how we can
benefit from this cellular separation
with high purities controlling for high
purity and this really enables the
downstream applications that especially
she is
talking about today thank you very much
and thank you so much salvador for that
wonderful presentation we now move to
kathy you may now begin your
presentation welcome kathy
uh thank you both thank you silva for a
really nice introduction uh to the
miltoni technology i'm going to give an
example of how we use that in our
laboratory now focusing on our work
studying mononuclear phagocytes in human
pregnancy using that automated high
purity isolation as kind of the the core
to what we do
so most of us will be familiar with
pregnancy and i put this up here we're
very familiar with many obvious changes
that occur in a pregnant woman's body as
she progresses from the early stages of
the pregnancy right through to delivery
of the baby
but some people may be uh
less familiar with some of the other
less obvious changes that occur in a
woman's body while she's pregnant and
amongst those changes
are things like the hormonal changes
which of course we're not very surprised
about this is a little summary here in
the corner and the most striking one
there is that human chorionic
gonodotropin very early in the pregnancy
and that's what we're measuring when we
do those we on stick pregnancy tests
very early uh in the journey to the
birth of the baby but there are lots of
other physiological changes that occur
as well and the example i just got here
is those changes in maternal blood
volume that increases and there are
changes in the cardiac rhythm but every
physiological system in pregnancy is
affected in some way
the part that i wanted to talk about
today is the metabolic changes that
occur in pregnancy and then how these
impinge on the immune function that
changes in the pregnant woman as well so
lots of metabolic changes occur in
pregnancy there are changes in the way
the mother uses those carbohydrates and
lipids and proteins she's taking from
her diet and she's changing the
substrate utilization of those to
support the growth and development of
the fetus but also of the placenta as
well and in the early stages of
pregnancy we see this initial anabolic
phase when it comes to metabolism and
the mother's laying down stores of
substrates and energy so pregnant eating
a little bit more um and laying down
lots of deposits of substrates
particularly within the adipose tissue
within her body and then we have a later
catabolic phase where the mother now
starts to break those down that those
all those components she's stored in the
adipose tissue and she's breaking those
down to meet the energy demands of both
herself and the placental and fetal
development that is really ramping up in
that second half of pregnancy
and this is a little cartoon summary of
some of those changes that are going on
on the left we've got what's going on in
very early pregnancy and on the right
we've got the changes that are occurring
as the pregnancy progresses as we've got
our key three metabolic tissues there
the liver the skeletal muscle and the
adipose tissue and in early pregnancy
there's
not huge differences to what is going on
in the non-pregnant woman but we can
start to see that increased uptake of
fatty acids particularly into the
adipose tissue and the laying down of
those lipid stools and we see amino
acids predominantly going to the baby as
the main source for the baby but there's
still glucose and fatty acids and then
on the right we can see that change that
occurs in the latter stages of pregnancy
there's less being put away and stored
in the adipose tissue and instead things
are fluxing out of the adipose tissue
now into the maternal circulation and
down to the placenta and the fetus so
you can see that baby's not only using
amino acids now there's lots of glucose
utilization by the baby as well and of
course the baby's using fatty acids but
not as extensively as it's using those
amino acids and the glucose as well
you're pressing the wrong button
okay so when we're thinking about those
metabolism substrates the glucose the
amino acids and the fatty acids that we
consume in our diet what we're thinking
about is their use by the cell through
the process of cellular metabolism and
therefore the production of eight atp
and all the biosynthetic intermediates
we need to build all of the proteins etc
that build our cells that make our
tissues that then enable our organs to
function so this is a little summary of
all those different cellular metabolic
pathways that are occurring in a cell
most of us will be familiar with
glycolysis we have here in number one
and also with oxidative phosphorylation
particularly occurring down in the
mitochondria but there's a number of
different pathways all summarized on
those slides and so this is important
for the uptake of glucose feeding
particularly through glycolysis there
then the uptake of glutamine feeding
through uh through glutamine metabolism
pathways and into the mitochondria and
into the t-cell cycle and onto oxidative
phospho oxidative phosphorylation and of
course our fatty acids are also coming
into the cell and contributing to fatty
acid oxidation properties and again
those cellular metabolic pathways that
are centered on the mitochondria so
these pathways are then those
underpinning pathways that enable the
cells to function and by having our
cells functioning properly of course all
our tissues and organs should be
functioning properly as well so this
little cartoon on the slide now is sort
of giving you a really overarching view
of what those metabolic changes that are
occurring in our pregnant women as they
progress from the first to the second to
the third trimester so i've already
mentioned we get that lipid accumulation
early in pregnancy and that wanes as the
pregnancy continues as the mother starts
to burn those livers starts to break
them down through products of lipolysis
and i bet if you ask any pregnant woman
if she thought she was burning a lot of
fat in those latter stages of
pregnancies she would probably say no
because she's obviously feeling quite
large because the baby's growing the
placenta is growing but she's now
burning fat really like a marathon
runner basically
so we see changes in glucose tolerance
that wanes as pregnancy progresses and
we see the emergence of insulin
resistance as a normal feature of
pregnancy and if this insulin resistance
is accelerated we see the emergence of
gestational diabetes
of course this all restores itself back
to pre-pregnancy states uh very soon
after the pregnancy is finished
and so we've been starting to think
about that link between those mandatory
metabolic changes that i've just
described to you and the immunological
changes that are also occurring as a
really important part of pregnancy
ensuring that the mother doesn't
immunologically reject the fetus and
many of you have been familiar with this
concept now of immuno metabolism so this
is changes in cellular metabolism as
determinants of immune cell fate and
function it's really just those cellular
metabolic pathways i've just described
and those working in immune cells such
as the monocytes that i'm going to talk
about today and there's a really big
literature now that looks at those
immunometabolic adaptations by our t
cells etc and find that these are linked
to changes in cytokine production the
ability of cells to phagocytize
phagocytose the proliferation of cells
reactive oxygen species production
susceptibility to death and a whole host
of effects effective functions
as i've already alluded to much of this
research is in t cells but we do see
quite a bit of it in macrophages
although admittedly they tend to be
neuromacrophage studies and we don't see
a lot in humans
and so we've been asking if there's that
intimate link between those metabolic
changes in pregnancy which are really
well known and well described
and maybe these are the key drivers of
the immune plasticity that is a really
typical feature of the pregnancy
and if we think about what's going on in
the immune system in terms of metabolism
you can see on this slide again on the
left i'm just reminding us that you know
there's nothing special about the
cellular metabolic pathways that are
occurring in immune cell they're just as
i described on that earlier slide we've
got glycolysis oxidative phosphorylation
and the metabolism of glucose amino
acids and fatty acids just like as in
any cell of the body but what's going on
in the immune system is shown on the
right side of the slide we've got a
whole host of other endogenous factors
that are going to impact on those
cellular metabolic processes and the
example on the little cartoon there are
thinking about the interaction with
cytokines in the microenvironment if
you're a t cell what happens after the t
cell receptor is triggered by mhc and
peptide and if you're a monocyte which
i'm going to talk about today what
happens after you get innate triggered
through the pattern recognition
receptors by a pathogen-associated
molecular patterns and we now understand
that that metabolic flux that occurs at
this time is fundamental to ensuring the
appropriate downstream response to those
signaling processes
and so if we now start thinking about
what those immune changes are in
pregnancy there's many and i don't want
to go into an exhaustive list of those
today but i thought the best one to use
as an example given we're talking about
monocytes and macrophages today is this
change in pro-inflammatory and
anti-inflammatory cytokines so you can
see at the top we see changes in both
the t-cell production of th1 and th2
cytokines but more broadly we see a flux
in the pro-inflammatory versus the
anti-inflammatory profile of a pregnant
woman so we follow the red line first
which is the pro-inflammatory process we
start here with sort of you know prior
to pregnancy we've got the menstrual
cycle there in the bottom left corner of
the graph and we see fluctuations in
inflammatory processes during that time
as well and then if a woman becomes
pregnant we see a heightened
pro-inflammatory response very early in
the pregnancy and this is actually a
really vital part of ensuring the
success of that early stage of pregnancy
ensuring that implantation occurs and
ensuring the placenta can invade into
the uterine wall then those
pro-inflammatory processes wane
following the solid red line and then
around the birth of the baby will see a
massive influx a massive increase in
these pro-inflammatory processes and
these are really important in the labor
process lots of inflammatory cytokines
involved in the labor process and the
triggering of the myometrial
contractions that don't expel the baby
but also the cervical dilatation that's
going to enable the cervix to open and
for the baby to get out and in contrast
our anti-inflammatory processes which
are there in the blue line
you can see they're showing the opposite
pattern as we would really expect to see
i think they're low early in pregnancy
they're elevated in the sort of second
and third trimester and help maintain
the environment that's going to ensure
that that baby is growing happily and
healthy in the womb and then they fall
around labor and then they have some
upswing in the period immediately after
labor and you may have noticed there's a
dotted red line on the graph as well and
that dotted red line is to indicate what
might happen in adverse pregnancy
outcomes this particularly relates to
what might happen in a woman who has
obesity during pregnancy or a woman who
has gestational diabetes they might
might not show that healthy natural
fluctuation in pro-inflammatory and
anti-inflammatory mediators and have a
disruption of that that then contributes
to the disease pathology that they are
presenting
so we're interested in what regulates
that normal adaptation over the course
of pregnancy but we're also asking lots
of questions around that in terms of
what is going on with the health of the
mother and the health of the baby so
we're not only interested in what is
normal we're also interested in how
different maternal environments might
drive changes in immuno-metabolic
adaptation i've already mentioned
gestational diabetes which is that
accelerated emergence of insulin
resistance and that of course will have
some profound effects on cellular
metabolic processes and we're interested
in maternal obesity and i'm going to
give a small example of that today of
course we've just had covert 19 pandemic
i say just had we're still in the throes
of it um and so lots of interest around
maternal infection which of course
predates clove at 19 as well and our
particular interest in my group is
looking at how mothers interact with the
you know the climate change that we're
encountering at the moment and the
possible effects of maternal pollution
exposures on some of these parameters
clearly we're interested in how these
metabolic adaptations are occurring in
the immune system and contributing to
adverse pregnancy outcomes as i said
i've mentioned gestational diabetes but
there's also huge interest in
preeclampsia and cholestasis which is an
itching disease of pregnancy associated
with changes in metabolism of
cholesterol and of course that impacts
on inflammatory pathways as well
and there's also lots and lots of
interest in how that maternal
environment during pregnancy is shaping
the development of the baby and
affecting that baby's health outcomes
for the future and so we're looking at
those immuno metabolic adaptations and
maladaptations and how they may be
shaping the development of the baby's
immune system in particular in terms of
my group but also how this may shape the
baby's susceptibility to certain
diseases once it's uh once it's born and
growing up uh through childhood and into
adulthood
and so this is the approach we're taking
for the studies that we do in in my
research group so we do a lot of work
with monocytes we've got to think about
the fact we're working with pregnant
women so there's quite a few ethical and
practical constraints to getting samples
from pregnant women and we're trying to
be as imaginative as we can be and think
about the kinds of samples that are that
are reasonable and feasible to collect
from pregnant women so we do a lot of
work with blood and the example i'm
going to give you today is monocytes we
can't go in and sample synovial joints
or any other kind of tissues so we're
doing a lot of work with monocyte
derived macrophages where we can
generate particular populations of
macrophages and then trying to do some
work with macrophages and i'm going to
give you the example of the placenta and
the placenta is a great organ because
it gives you an offering of these
primary human macrophages that you can
use in the study of obstetrics and
pregnancy but you can also think about
them as an accessible population of
human primary macrophages which are
relatively hard to get you can get
alveolar macrophages and probably breast
milk macrophages alongside with
placental macrophages are the most
accessible in terms of human studies
and on the right i mean i'm not sure how
well that's projecting but there's a
kind of example of the approach we're
taking looking at that relationship
between all of those mononuclear
phagocytes and pregnancy we're looking
at them in the circulation we're looking
at them in pregnancy we're thinking
about the effects of obesity and
pregnancy so we also think about the
effects of obesity and the non-pregnant
woman as well as men we're starting to
try to do some work with adipose tissue
thinking about women who have cesarean
sections we can get the adipose tissue
from these women and there's already
people working with this and trying to
understand what's going on in that
adipose tissue environment and then in
terms of what's going on in the uterus
in pregnancy we have a tissue called the
decitua and the decidua is the modified
endometrium so the endometrium would
normally be shed if a woman is not
pregnant but if she's pregnant and
undergoes a process called
decidualization
and then it's exquisitely positioned to
support the implantation of the embryo
and those very early stages of pregnancy
but we still have it in the latter
stages of pregnancy and it's a
relatively accessible tissue i did my
phd on decidual macrophages for example
and again we can look at this in
different scenarios and our focus on
this slide is particularly obesity and
then we have the placenta itself and
there's immense interest in the effects
of maternal obesity and other maternal
environmental factors on the placenta
we've seen some papers on clover 19
responses in the placenta and lots of
work around obesity and again you can
see that approach taken there taking
samples from women of different bmis
lean women and obese women and comparing
the function of the placenta more widely
but we can go in and isolate different
populations as well
and so this is now summarizing the
strategy that we take in my laboratory
so we've already seen a little bit of
this from the work selva presented so we
take our whole blood samples and we do
some work with whole blood and i'm going
to give you one particular example of
that we then make mononuclear cells
we're still on density centrifugation
but we are at the moment trialling the
untouched pbmc kit from miltoni to make
sure that we can swap it out with the
density gradient centrifugation that has
been the historical method of choice
this gives us those mononuclear cells or
those peripheral blood mononuclear cells
and then we can take those mononuclear
cells and we can do something with them
as well depending on what the study is
but more often than not we will take
those mononuclear cells through to our
automax and then we will isolate cd14
positive monocytes from them we use a
positive selection strategy that selva's
already explained to you today we have
explored negative selection strategies
as well uh and negative selection
strategies are perfectly fabulous if
you're using not pregnant samples and
children and all kinds of things but if
you try to do them on pregnant women you
get way too many platelets carried
through so
we typically deploy a positive selection
process
so we can take our monocytes and then we
can use them for lots of different
downstream applications and the examples
i'm going to talk today i'm going to
give you an example of mass spectrometry
an example of extracellular flux
analysis and an example of
transcriptomics on the nanostring and
i'll explain each of them when we get
them
we can also take those monocytes and
under define cytokine environments turn
them into macrophage populations because
there's lots of preceding work in the
literature that says if you expose the
monocytes to cytokine a b and c they
will be they will develop into
macrophages that behave like a
particular type of tissue residual
macrophage and i'm going to talk about
one population in particular
and of course the other thing we do is
we take our placenta and we can mush our
placenta up we can enzymatically digest
it we can do our density centrifugation
and we can take through to our
macrophages in this case using the same
cd14 like microbeads that we use for the
blood and the monocytes
so thinking about this journey that's
what i'm going to take you through for
the remainder of the presentation this
afternoon this morning wherever you may
be in the world
so thinking about our whole blood
strategy there's lots of fabulous things
you can do with whole blood and you
don't have to do any downstream
processing you can go straight to whole
blood flow cytometry and the example
i've got here and it's a a kit we find
highly valuable in the lab is the eight
color immunophenotyping kit we can use
an automated hematology analysis
approach and that will give us
information about our monocytes our
neutrophils like eosinophils our
lymphocytes in total as well as our
basophils but it won't give us any
indication of the lymphocyte subsets our
monocyte subsets um that might give
added value to the analysis we're doing
so here we can use whole blood we can
use the eight color immunophenotyping
kit we can use a really well defined
flow cytometry gating strategy that's
shown on the slide here and then we can
go in and quantify those all those
different cell populations you can see
listed on the the left hand side of the
slide there
and then we can compare those in our
different populations and we've used
this to look at pregnant women who have
high bmi versus pregnant women who have
a low normal weight bmi and we've done
this in peripheral blood that we've
taken from women when they're 28 weeks
of pregnancy and we've only used women
who are negative for gestational
diabetes
as we can find lots of fabulous
differences in the peripheral immune
cells of women with and without obesity
at 28 weeks of pregnancy and i put a few
examples up here i didn't want to go
into too much detail this paper has just
been published so if you're interested
in finding out more about it
you can follow up the publication as
well but the three examples i've got
here on the slide the top left one is
looking at that t cell ratio so using
the immunophenotyping kit we can
enumerate the cd4 and cd8 t cells and
look at changes in the total numbers of
those and we can also calculate our cd4
to cda ratio and you can see there's a
dramatic change in that with the
mother's bmi there's a wayne a decline
in cd8 cells in particular and so the
cd4 cd8 ratio
and this has been described in uh not
pregnant people with obesity as well and
similarly up on the top right we can
look at our nkt cells and we can see
that nice decline that occurs in nkt
cell numbers in the circulation of women
as their bmi increases during that
pregnancy
and again this is something that's also
been shown in not pregnant people as
well
on the bot on the bottom panel there
we've got our monocytes a little bit
less startling than the top two
observations but we can able to go in
and subset the three different types of
monocytes the classical monocytes the
intermediate monocytes and the
non-classical monocytes and look at
those three different subsets which are
differentiated by this cd16 expression
and you can see that in the case of the
intermediate monocytes which are the
little blue squares there's a sort of
slot a slight decline of those with
increasing maternal bmi and we've done a
whole pile of extra work on these
samples and we've gone on and shown lots
of different uh changes and those are
summarized on these slides here we've
looked at circulating parameters showing
that there are changes in things like
lepton and interleukin-6 and mcp1 or ccl
22 i think it is
these are increased in the circulation
of pregnant obese women just like we
would see in non-pregnant obese people
i've highlighted that cd4 cd8 and nkc
tell c n k t cell changes
and we see changes in those monocytes we
see the decline in the in the
intermediate population but overall in
our monocytes we see a decline in the
mitochondria and we see changes in
various surface markers on these cells
using a whole range of flow cytometry
and we can see changes in the th1 th2
t-reg th17 balance in these pregnant
women and what we see are a lot of
things that are reminiscent of what we
see in non-pregnant women but we've now
confirmed that they're occurring in
pregnant women and again if you're
interested i refer you to that paper
that's just been published in clinical
experimental immunology
so that's thinking about our whole blood
approach now we're thinking about our
mononuclear cells and we're taking them
through using our cd14 microbeads that
selva introduced you to using the
methods you introduced you to and
positively selecting our cd14 positive
mo our cd14 positive monocytes and we
get nice purity we would run at about a
92 to 95 percent purity of the cells uh
most days in my laboratory
and so we can use these for a whole host
of downstream uh analyses and i'm just
going to walk you through a few examples
of those different types of approaches
that we take so the first one is just
you know
i don't want to say straightforward
simple flow cytometry i love flow
cytometry it's a great tool
it's one of the key tools that we use in
my laboratory but we can do lots of
powerful things of course we can do this
in our whole blood and i've already
given you an example and we can do it on
our mononuclear cells but because we're
ultimately interested in potentially
subsetting these based on their cd16
expression we've gone with a
uh
using our purified monocytes for much of
this analysis but again it depends on
the studies we're doing so here we're
just looking at cd16 expression of those
monocytes that we've isolated and here
we're now moving into studies of women
at term pregnancies so these are women
just a few days to a few weeks before
they have their babies uh after 37 weeks
of gestation
and so we can use cd16 uh to stain the
cells and then we can see there are
differences in the relative abundance of
those two major monocyte subsets the
cd16 positive non-classical monocytes
and the cd16 negative classical
monocytes and we're not the first to
describe this we're confirming you know
previous literature but pregnant women
have an increase in that cd16 positive
subset and if you look at different
stages of pregnancy you will see these
increasing as the pregnancy progresses
we can also look in more detail at those
cells using other tools and the examples
i've got here is the flow cytometry
through the middle of the slide there is
using miter tracker to look at the
mitochondrial content of our monocytes
and here again we're using cd16 to
identify our classical and our
non-classical subsets and then we're
using mitre tracker to provide a
quantitative measure of the
mitochondrial mass in those monocytes
and we've got the little black circles
there are our not pregnant women and the
little blue squares are our pregnant
women and on the left we've got our
non-classical
16 positive monocytes and on the right
are classical and you can see that in
both populations of our monocytes we see
a decrease in the mitochondria the
mitochondrial content in our pregnant
women so to us that was a really
interesting observation
and we were able to confirm this by
taking those really nicely purified
monocytes and doing some mass
spectrometry on them we were able to do
mass spectrometry for cardiolipin which
is the the graph on the bottom there
gray is again are not pregnant and blue
is our pregnant women and you can see a
nice difference in the cardio lip and
content of these cells as well and
cardiolipin is a lipid that's
particularly expressed within the
mitochondria and so this is confirming
the fact that these monocytes from our
pregnant women have a reduction in their
mitochondrial content
having seen a reduction in the
mitochondrial content of our monocytes
using a strategy that's really enabled
us to look at the same cells for their
miter tracker expression and take them
through to mass spectrometry as well to
do the cardio lipid analysis we then
wanted to look at the functional
responses of these cells so the method
the methodological approach we then took
was to do extracellular flux analysis
anyone who is familiar with this might
call it seahorse analysis which confuses
people people are always a bit surprised
when we use the terminology because they
know we're a human immunology lab and
they get very confused when we mention
seahorses and we have to explain it's
just the the
slang name for the piece of equipment
but this particular piece of equipment
allows you to actually measure
oxidative phosphorylation and glycolysis
in intact cells and we do this on our
monocytes as i'm showing you here today
but we do it on t cells and eosinophils
and neutrophils and all kinds of immune
cells
and this enables you to do um to inject
the cells with a whole host of different
inhibitors and activators and uncouplers
of the different like different
metabolic processes within the cell so
you can see the little table on the
bottom left it's got the four key drugs
that i'm going to be using in the assays
i'm talking about today and we can
inject these in different sequences and
then we can measure what's called the
oxygen consumption rate up on the top
right there of the slide or we can
measure the extracellular acidification
rate which is in the bottom right there
of the slide
and the opposite opposite consumption
which you know use the shorthand of
occur allows us all kinds of measures of
oxidative phosphorylation you can use
different points on that that graph
that's or that that trace that is
generated and you can calculate
different things such as spare
respiratory capacity maximum represent
maximal respiration and a whole host of
different parameters and then equally on
the bottom you can do the same thing but
here you're measuring extra cellular
acidification rate which is a measure of
glycolysis and again you can look at
various glycolysis parameters using the
data that you generate in that trace so
we took our monocytes that we purified
on the auto max and we were able to put
them into the plates for the actual
cellular flux analysis
and then we can generate those oxygen
consumption rate traces and those extra
cellular acidification rate traces as
i've given you the example on the
previous slide so that's what's now
shown on this slide again we've taken
monocytes around non-pregnant and
pregnant women at 37 plus weeks such as
the most startling thing you'll see is
the oxidative consumption rate again our
pregnant women are in blue and you can
see they have a very reduced oxidative
consumption rate suggesting they've got
reduced oxidative phosphorylation and
you can see that summarized in the graph
below is the respiration rate calculated
from that trace above and you can see
that maximal respiration rate is
different significantly reduced in our
pregnant women on the right we've got
glycolysis and we can see there's not
any real significant difference in the
glycolysis that's occurring in these
cells and to us of course that made
sense we knew our monocytes had less
mitochondria in them so it was perhaps
not surprising that we looked at
cellular metabolism focusing on
oxidative phosphorylation and glycolysis
it was only oxidative phosphorylation
that showed that decline in our pregnant
women
and then we wanted to see what the
functional consequences of that were
those for those effective function that
the cell is doing so we know we've got
that fewer mitochondria we know that
there's less oxidative phosphorylation
in these cells from our pregnant women
well what's going on in terms of an
effector response by those monocytes and
we use cytokine readout to look at that
but of course you have to be very
thoughtful about what you stimulate your
cells with lots of people would
stimulate their cells with liver
polysaccharide for example which is what
we did and we didn't find much of a
difference the lipid polysaccharide
activity is very dependent on glycolysis
and we knew that glycolysis was not
dampened in our cells from our pregnant
women so we searched around for
something that may be a stimulus that
was dependent on oxidative
phosphorylation and we set it on muramal
dipeptide or mdp which is a nod to nlr
ligand and you can see the cytokine
responses from our pregnant are not
pregnant women on the right and we can
see reduced interleukin 1 beta
significantly reduced interleukin-6 and
tnf alpha in the cells from our pregnant
women indicating that
poor oxidative phosphorylation that
lesser mitochondrial mass is having that
functional effect on the cells
and so we wanted to really get in and
understand why this may be occurring so
we then did transcriptomics on the cell
and we use the nanostring
encounter sprint profiler and on this
you can you can analyze 800 target genes
on your cells you only need about 80 000
cells we chose the encounter metabolic
pathways panel because we're interested
in cellular metabolism and in our case
this was particularly beneficial because
we didn't have to extract rna we could
make cell lysate so meant we could uh
increase the workflow and we could also
ensure that we were getting good
fidelity about of our assays just on
those very small numbers of cells that
you can use there and the little cartoon
on the right there is just the workflow
for the for how the nanostream works
and so then the kinds of readouts you
get there are those things you see in
all the papers on transcriptomics you
can take this volcano plot on the left
here which is gene by gene analysis and
here we're looking you know on the right
of the volcano with things that are
higher in our pregnant women compared to
our not pregnant women and on the left
we've got those things that are lower
you know not pre in our pregnant women
versus them not pregnant women and we
can see there's lots of genes of
interest that have come up and we're
pursuing those at the moment
we can also take a sort of more heat map
approach and we can see that heat map
analysis on the right here we've got our
not pregnant women on the top of the
heat map not pregnant one to six and
then our pregnant women down the bottom
we've got different pathways
along the y-axis of the heat map and a
blue is an increase in expression and
the amber is a decrease in expression
and there's lots of different pathways
in this in this
metabolic pathways panel that are up and
down regulated in our pregnant women
these include amino acid synthesis
mitochondrial respiration and so again
they're helping us understand what's
going on in those pregnant women
so just to summarize that before we get
to just a few examples of the monocyte
derived macrophages and the placental
macrophages
we showed that there was an increase in
the non-classical monocytes in pregnancy
confirming what was already known but we
were the first to show this reduced
mitochondrial content using our flow
cytometry and our mass spectrometry of
our really highly purified monocytes
we've showed reduced oxidative
phosphorylation and that this is
associated with decreased response to a
pathogen-associated molecular pattern as
long as that pamp is dependent on
oxidative phosphorylation and we can see
relevant changes in our metabolic
pathways using that nanostring-based
transcriptomics so immunometabolic
adaptation is definitely occurring in
the monocytes of these pregnant women
and we're now trying to understand why
and sort of the timelines of this during
the pregnancy
and so some of the other things we're
doing as well and i touched on this
earlier in the presentation we've talked
about the monocytes in the blood but i
just want to give you a couple of
examples in the last few slides of
monocyte derived macrophages and our
macrophages from our tissues
so this is the only example of our
monocyte derived macrophages we're
looking at monocyte-derived osteoclasts
in particular and here we're taking out
you know unnicely pure monocytes we then
expose them to that defined cytokine
environment which in this case is mcsf
and rank ligand and we culture the cells
in this for 11 to 14 days and over that
period they very nicely turn into these
highly sensitized osteoclasts the
macrophages that we would find in the
bone for example these are the macros we
would find in the bone and you can see
the confocal microscopy along the bottom
there de naught we can see our beautiful
little monocytes that little
uh the red is the cytoplasm or the sorry
the plasma membrane and the blue is the
nucleus and you can see the nice kidney
shape of our monocyte nucleus and then
over the course of the culture and the
presence of those two cytokines they
start to merge these different monocytes
and they form these multi-nucleated
giant cells which you can see in the
other images there we can see cells with
you know six seven nuclei inside them
and then we're staining them with trap
and trap antibody which is a antibody
for an enzyme that this particular cell
type produces which helps it degrade the
bone then we've got tom 20 which is a
mitochondrial stain so you can see those
green mitochondria clustering around the
nuclei and then we've got the rank
antibody which is the receptor for the
rank ligand we use to differentiate
cells
the very last thing i want to do is talk
about that placenta we get that placenta
it's a natural waste product after the
baby's born it normally gets chucked out
by the clinical team so we we acquire
that and then we take it and we process
it through for macrophages and you can
see the fetal side there on the left
which has got the umbilical cord coming
out which of course will be attached to
what becomes all of our belly buttons
and then we've got the maternal side
down there
and we're taking a very similar approach
that i've got to like i've already
described to you we take our placentas
we take them from women of different
bmis is what i'm talking about today and
we isolate those placental macrophages
and again we use the auto max to do this
and we're taking a very similar strategy
to what i've described with the monocyte
so i'm not going to go into any great
detail we use the seahorse analyzer the
extracellular flux analysis and we can
see the oxidative consumption as a
measure of oxidative phosphorylation we
can see the extracellular acidification
as a measure of glycolysis
and it's a little bit more complicated
than what i showed you with the
monocytes because here we've looked at
the cells after they've been cultured in
either the absence or presence of
lipopolysaccharide and what we found was
those macrophages from our obese women
and here we use women who have a bmi
greater than 35 so they're you know
they're
they're quite obese by this stage and
we're comparing them to lean women and
we can see that there is a dramatic
difference the macrophages from our
obese women have very reduced oxidative
phosphorylation but they also have very
reduced glycolysis so we're now trying
to tease apart what that means
functionally for the cells
i just want to give you one example of
how we can analyze those functionally we
can use a
frodo labeled e-coli to look at the
phagocytosis of these cells here outside
the cell ph
stops the fluorescence of the frodo
labeled e coli but once the e coli is
internalized and the ph of the lysosome
they're exposed to the ph of the
lysosome they will start to fluoresce
and can be detected on the flow
cytometer so we can do lots of lovely
flow cytometry analysis there as well
and then what we found on the right was
that our obese women again in that
pinkish color have much reduced
phagocytosis especially as you're
increasing the amount of bacteria
they've been exposed to their
phagocytosis is limited and we're now
trying to understand how that altered
phagocytosis is linked to those altered
metabolic processes we described in
those cells using extracellular flux
analysis
and so just looking at
um this last bit of work here looking at
that placental macrophage immuno
metabolism we know there's some kind of
functional metabolism
occurring in these cells and we're now
looking at how that may be associated
with gestational diabetes and various
other pregnancy disorders and placental
dysfunction inflammation
liver toxicity the things that are
actually going on in the placenta and
then thinking about what that means for
the baby
and so just to summarize there's that
strategy that we've been using
throughout the presentation i've given
you today where that automax
high purity isolation of ourselves sits
right at the center and it enables us to
do all those downstream analysis uh
analysis processes that i've presented
you today and it also underpins our
other work in our macrophage setting
both the monocyte derived macrophages
and those tissue macrophages we can
isolate from the placenta
and this last slide really is just to
remind you this is really advertising
what my laboratory group does and so
this is a strategy we're using to try
and understand that pregnancy
environment in its most natural of
states but also how it may be perturbed
in response to different environmental
influences and the role of the monocytes
and the macrophages in particular in
that
so just on the last slide i'd just like
to firstly thank from miltoni for
inviting me along today to talk about
the work we're doing on mononuclear
phagocytes and just thank the people in
my team so april reece did her phd on
the monocyte work and recently
successfully awarded that hamza nasa is
doing the monocyte derived macrophage
work and med chambers is doing the
placental work
and we really couldn't do the work
without the midwives up on the antenatal
unit the central delivery suite and we
absolutely could not do the work if it
wasn't for the women who agree to be
part of our studies and let's let us
take their placentas and their blood and
along the bottom is just some of the
various people we collaborate with
thank you everybody
and thank you kathy and salvador for
that informative presentation we will
now start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you
want to ask please do so now just click
on that ask a question box located on
the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
and it looks like we already have some
great questions coming in from our
audience our first question
goes to you kathy
can we identify or predict pregnant
women prone to number one a high rate of
pre-eclampsia and number two pre-term
birth especially during their first
pregnancy in obstetrics hospitals
perhaps using the max technology at
different stages of pregnancy to detect
maternal mal immuno metabolism
uh that's an excellent question it is
something that we are trying to do you
know i presented lots of work today
about what happens in a normal pregnancy
the effects of obesity particularly in
the latter stages of pregnancy we're
trying to take that work back to much
earlier in pregnancy and try and
understand what is going on with some of
those immunometabolic approaches and
also try new strategies that we can you
know try and measure what's going on in
the placenta as well without actually
accessing the placenta so it's
definitely the thrust of our work at the
moment
thank you so much and our next question
does clinical symptomology of
pre-existing autoimmune disorders in
pregnant women worsen during their
pregnancy
another excellent question it really
depends on the autoimmune disease that
the woman has prior to the pregnancy so
a woman with rheumatoid arthritis or
multiple sclerosis will actually show
improvements in their disease
so particularly in the third trimester
of pregnancy a woman with relapsing
remitting multiple sclerosis for example
would show fewer relapses compared to
her own relapse rates prior to the
pregnancy and then she will often crash
into a relapse in the first few months
after the baby is born and the same with
women with rheumatoid arthritis they'll
have fewer flares during the pregnancy
whereas a woman who's got systemic lupus
arithmetosis will actually get worsening
disease so it really depends on what her
autoimmune disease but again we do see
that pregnancy has quite a profound
effect on that autoimmune disease
profile probably driven by those immune
plasticity changes that are occurring in
the pregnant woman
thank you so much now you showed a
solution for untouched
pbmc isolation
is it possible to do further magnetic
isolations after the pbmc isolation kit
you can take this one um yes so the
isolation is completely untouched so
your pvmcs are have no microbeads on
them so you can then
use any of the kits i showed before to
isolate further uh cells that you might
be interested in so you could
isolate only monocytes but t cells b
cells whatever you are interested in
thank you very much salvador and i want
to thank our audience for these great
questions coming in
do these
um how long does the immune system take
to go back to basil levels after
pregnancy
well i think the the short answer is
nobody actually knows because not a lot
of people actually a lot of studies in
pregnancy and a lot of studies in the
second and third trimester of pregnancy
but not a lot of studies on those immune
changes that may be occurring very early
on from just before the conception
through the first trimester and then not
very many after the pregnancy so um
there's been some nice studies recently
showing immunometabolic or metabolic
changes but again they started at five
weeks of pregnancy and stopped when the
baby was born so we've actually just
started some work i've got a student who
should be in the lab right now working
on some samples where we're going to
follow the women from right at the end
of the pregnancy through the first six
months after the baby is born
in the first instance
and we're also to try and work out what
that timeline of going back to
pre-pregnancy levels is but we're also
interested in the possibility that there
still may be an echo of the pregnancy
for many many years in the in the
woman's future so there may be some kind
of evidence of that immune plasticity
that has occurred during pregnancy that
has a long lasting and profound effect
on her own immune system but you know we
need a bit of time to work that out
thank you so much now salvador and kathy
do these changes continue during
breastfeeding
it's another really good question so
we've we've been trying to do some work
on breast milk macrophages in much like
i've shown you here today they're a bit
more challenging to isolate you would
think that would be easier because they
come in liquid form already but um there
are some challenges just because of the
high fat content in the in the milk and
you can skim the milk and try and
isolate them but they are very
challenging to isolate so again we're
trying to we're trying to look at some
of these changes some of those changes
that happen postpartum
trying to perhaps think about are they
different in a woman who breastfeeds
versus a woman who doesn't breastfeed so
we are trying to look at that in again a
little bit more detail
thank you so much now if we use straight
from
to isolate cd14
can we isolate other cells from the same
original sample
um i can take this one too yes uh as it
is a positive selection uh you will only
be labeling the cells of interest in
this case cd14 so if you collect the
flow through of the negative
uh cells those cells are untouched so
you can then proceed with other positive
selections or untouched
selections if you would like to so it's
a common
protocol to for example do straight from
cd14 and then you grab the negative
negative sample and then you go for
straight from cd8 or cd4 for example
thank you both so much now how many
cells do you need to perform
all the downstream applications
and
do you have a threshold of purity and
recovery for your isolated cells that
will be used for sea horse or nano
string etc
yeah i'll take this one so
um i i think i mentioned it during the
presentation so we run at about 90 to 92
to 95 purity which would be our standard
purity so we would take those through uh
we would very rarely get anything less
than that and we would probably not take
it through to any of these analysis if
we did and then the number you need
really depends on the on the platform
that you're on we try to because we work
in pregnancy you can't get you know vast
amounts of blood we get about 30 to 35
mls of blood from our pregnant women we
do work with um umbilical cords and
finger pricks and
uh heel pricks as well so we've tried to
do things that don't need very many
cells so then the sea horse does need
quite a few cells you need about 200 000
cells per well and you need to do
multiple replicates and so you do need a
good few million cells to do that
analysis but the nano string is you know
i really like it because you only need
that 60 to 80 000 cells to really get a
good a good comparison you can do those
800 odd genes on that and our mass
spectrometry approaches we've whittled
down to some kind you know around about
100 100 000 cells as well so we work
really hard on reducing the cell numbers
thank you so now so much now what are
your tips
for the best results
you owe me silva
my tip is
it's better to hear from you yeah yeah
my tip is to just
be religious in your approach to
following the protocol i can give you an
example of many years ago when i in my
in the laboratory i worked in prior to
moving to swansea i had a a student who
was bemoaning the fact that their max
separation wasn't working i sat with
them one day and they were doing
something as simple as you know it's
meant to go in the fridge but they were
putting on ice and so that changes the
the temperature that everything was
being done and when they went back and
followed the protocol faithfully
then everything worked particularly well
so that's my main advice is to be
faithful to the protocol
you for very much we have one final
question that has come in
we have seen difficult i'm sorry we have
seen different protocols showing
different speeds through the column
is there a possibility to do a control
the flow also manually and do you always
need an instrument for this
you don't always need an instrument for
this you can also control the flow rate
uh manually
by simply using different kinds of
columns we have
some columns that are
uh used for
reducing the flow the flow rate and so
with those ones you will enrich for uh
recovery if you're going for positive
selection and we have other columns that
will uh have a higher flow through
flow rate and then this will uh enrich
for
purity in if you're going for positive
selection so you don't always need an
instrument for this
and if i could perhaps just add we
started our
isolations just using the simple manual
flow through columns and as we you know
developed and integrated into our
protocols and had more people
using these particular
protocols we then progressed to the
automated system and it's such an
integral part of our workflow now that i
just took delivery of a second auto max
so that we can um have two different
workflows operating in the laboratory
kathy and salvador i want to thank you
for your time today and for your
important research
would you like to provide any final
comments for our audience before we go
i'll start with you salvador
if they if somebody's interested for
demos or any of the
hits or instruments that we've commented
today just
let us know contact your sales reps or
simply go into the websites that i added
before and we will be super happy to
help you
thank you so much and kathy
and it's the same for from my
perspective as well if anyone's
interested if anyone's interested in the
methods we're using or and or some of
the readouts we're using some of the
platforms we have running then please
just email me and i'm happy to help in
any way i can
well i want to thank you both again for
your time
and for your wonderful presentation and
i'd also like to thank lab roots and our
sponsor miltoni biotech for underwriting
today's educational webcast and before
we go i want to thank our audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by our speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration and this
webcast can be viewed on demand vibrates
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time take care everyone
bye-bye
you